let's go next to our caller from the
seven five seven area code who's calling
today from seven five seven all right
David this is Micah hey Micah I am
calling because recently I kind of
switched sides from not really from left
to right but on positions involving
abortion and I was wondering why you
wouldn't consider abortion human rights
issue I mean I so when we say a human
rights issue different people mean
different things i I think it there's no
question that the issue of abortion
relates to the rights of humans
specifically women and the people that
they are potentially in relationships
with that could lead to offspring to
decide what is best for them in the
situation in which they find themselves
so in that case it is a human rights
issue but sometimes people mean
something very specific when they say a
human rights issue so maybe tell me more
what you're thinking
yeah I'm thinking of a different
perspective as in so say a baby or if
you want to call it a fetus I guess if
we can we can agree if fetus is human
there's a fetus human so this gets
immediately into a question that science
religion and philosophy all have
different views on it's sort of like you
know with with the the issue of is a
fetus perfectly well at what point in
the pregnancy conception I guess we
could say I don't believe that a fetus
at conception is a fetus first of all at
that point I don't even know that we
call it a fetus and I don't think it's a
person at that point okay right it's not
a person because personhood is like a
state thing but the humanity of it this
is where I kind of changed my positions
is that I checked it out from a science
for
spective and it seems to me yeah that
conception is where humanity starts you
know human DNA would equal humanity in
that sense and you think it starts at
conception - yeah yeah yeah unless it
could be proven otherwise it seems to me
that humanity starts at conception
therefore abortion from the perspective
of the human inside of the woman not the
woman's body the body inside of the
woman so hold on because I think you're
getting it something interesting you
concede that at conception we're not
dealing with a person right you said
that a couple minutes ago as far as I
understand I just want to make sure that
misstating a you you agree at conception
we're not dealing with a person right
okay I know it's as far as you I get it
it's all your opinion
at conception we're not dealing with a
person but you said conception is the
start of humanity on the basis of the
DNA is am i understanding your position
correctly the distinction being
personhood versus human I I totally
understand that is that what I'm trying
to do is before I move on I'm trying to
establish your position so if what
you're saying is really humanity is
starting at conception because that's
when the DNA is is surfacing in reality
the DNA pre-exists that right because
the woman has eggs and the man has sperm
isn't that same DNA in the man and the
woman that conceived the child already
in your sense you've been by your
definition really humanity even starts
before conception so then it makes it a
question whether it should really have
anything to do with abortion at all
right and I think I worded it slightly
wrong but the point is that there's a
it's not just human DNA right isn't a
skin soul or whatever but uh it's like
the unique genetic code I'm not sure
exactly how to you know scientifically
put it to you but
you know where there's a new human a new
DNA that's you know separate from the
mothers okay and now there are that how
does that inform your view on abortion
because at that point I would see it as
human rights like that is a human just
because it's out of early stage of its
process of growing doesn't make it any
less human and human rights would
envelop that that you know humans have
the right to life you can't just kill a
human
abortion is not murder only because it's
legal you know if it was illegal it be
murder murder legal term oh so right now
basically forcing now from the more from
the point of conception because even
though you agree a conception it's not a
person but it's humanity am I getting
that I mean that's not the whole
position I take if the mother's life is
in danger you know at that point the
mother and the child are gonna die so to
save the mother's life I think abortion
could be you know that's the only sense
I could see it being purely a good thing
and not good inside the humans dying but
you know to save the mother's life all
right very good
I'm not totally I know it's all based on
your opinion no I understand that it's
it so you and I have a difference of
opinion I'm not a hundred percent
following the logic of how you came to
this but I do appreciate you sharing
with it sharing it with me and maybe
it'll it'll be useful to some folks that
are that are listening today